The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We want
to start talking
about a seemingly
simple but very complex
system in physics, the
harmonic oscillator.
So the next part is actually
due to Professor Vladan Vuletic,
who worked out the
topic very nicely about,
how precisely can you
measure frequencies?
And I don't need to
remind you that some
of the most accurate
measurements in all of physics
are done by measuring frequency.
It's actually a kind
of unwritten rule.
If you want to measure
something precisely,
make sure that you find a
way that this quantity can
be measured in a
frequency measurement.
Because frequencies,
that's what we
can measure-- with synthesizers,
with clocks, and such.
So therefore, the question,
how precisely can you
measure frequency, is a
question which is actually
relevant for all
precision measurements.
Well, we know we
have Fourier theorem.
If you have an oscillator which
oscillates for a time delta t,
we have the Fourier
theorem which
says we have a finite width of
the frequency spectrum delta
omega, or there is the spread
of frequency components involved
in such a way that delta
omega times delta t
is large or equal than 1/2.
The case of 1/2 is realized
for Gaussian wave packets.
And of course, Fourier theorem
should also-- this Fourier
limit should remind you of
Heisenberg's uncertainty
relation.
Of course, Fourier limit and
Heisenberg uncertainty relation
are related because what
Heisenberg expressed
turns out to be simply
the limit due to the wave
nature of matter.
OK.
So I brought the
clicker because I
want you to think about some
seemingly simple question.
The first question is whether
the uncertainty delta omega
times delta t larger than
1/2, does this uncertainty
hold for purely
classical systems?
So think about it and
answer in your clicker.
A is 1 and B-- oh,
I should say that.
So we now assume we have a
purely classical-- you can even
think a mechanical,
large mechanical object,
purely classical
harmonic oscillator.
You can observe it
for time delta t,
or it oscillates
for time delta t.
Can you determine its
frequency better then
this uncertainty suggests?
19, 20.
Just make up your mind.
As I said, your
responses are not
recorded, so nothing to risk.
OK.
Yes.
OK, the majority gave
the right answer.
The situation is that
the answer is yes,
if you have a good
signal to noise ratio.
So what happens is, if you--
we have to bring in the fact
that we have noise.
So if you have a wave formed,
there may be noise around it.
And if you look at the spectrum,
the spectral components
have a certain width.
And this width, delta omega,
is given by Fourier's theorem
by the time delta t you
had for observation.
But as you see, you can
determine the center
of this spectral peak with an
accuracy delta omega, which
may be much better than the
[? width ?] delta omega.
And the rule of
thumb is that you
can split a line by your
signal to noise ratio.
So typically, the
accuracy of a measurement
is whatever the width
of the spectrum is,
and then you can split the line
by the signal to noise ratio.
This is called
splitting the line.
Factor of hundred is usually
regarded as straightforward.
But if you want to go
to larger than that,
it becomes a challenge.
Because even if you have a very
good signal to noise ratio,
you really have to make sure
that you know the line shape,
that you know that it is,
for instance, symmetric,
and that the line center
of the observed shape
is really where
the frequency is.
I will give you some
examples in a few moments.
But before that, I would like
to continue our discussion
whether we can measure
the angle of frequency
to better than the
Heisenberg limit
in case of a
quantum-mechanical oscillator.
So the question is, can
you measure the frequency
of a quantum-mechanical harmonic
oscillator in a time delta t
to an accuracy which is better
than the limit of Heisenberg's
uncertainty?
OK, your vote, please.
All right.
OK.
Why don't we hold
that for a second
and proceed to the next
question which is the same?
But now, instead of a
quantum-mechanical harmonic
oscillator, we take
something we are
very familiar with--
an optical laser--
and we observe a laser pulse
lasting a duration delta t.
So same situation, but
instead of observing
a quantum-mechanical
harmonic oscillator,
we observe a laser pulse.
For the laser, can we
measure the frequency
of the optical radiation better
than this equality tells us?
OK.
At least people are consistent
because the first thing
I wanted to tell you is
that, is the laser actually
a classical harmonic oscillator
or quantum harmonic oscillator?
Well, we use a
quantum description
of light and the laser is
the population of photons
in the single note of the
electromagnetic field.
So in that sense, the
laser is fully quantum.
But in the limit that
the laser is many,
many photons-- and some of you
know about coherence states.
If there's a coherent state
with a large photon number,
the laser is actually
the classical limit
of an electromagnetic field.
So maybe that tells
me that the answers
to questions 2 and question 3
should probably be the same.
And I want to say more about it.
So at least in this class,
you were consistent.
I have often seen
a big discrepancy
in the answers between
question 2 and question 3.
OK, so the answer is yes.
So both for the laser-- I
first explain the laser to you,
and then we go back to the
pure quantum system, thing
has actually certain subtleties.
But for the laser,
it is obvious,
at least if I tell you
how I want to measure it,
because I can take the
laser and create a beat
note with another
very stable laser.
And I record this beat
note on a photodiode.
I can realize by making
this other laser,
the local oscillator
stronger and stronger,
I can create a
beat note which is
larger and larger
and corresponds
to a macroscopic
electric current which
can be measured with
very high precision.
So you can realize an
arbitrarily high signal
to noise ratio by using a
strong local oscillator.
And then you can actually
say the photocurrent, which
comes out of the
photodiode, is actually--
you can regard this microscopic
current as purely classical.
And then of course, the answer
to the first question applies.
So that takes care of question
3 by mapping it actually
on question 2.
But now by saying
that the laser also
has a quantum-mechanical limit
and I'm not changing anything,
we realize that probably
the answer to question 2
should also be yes.
So let's, therefore,
ask our self, what
is the situation when the
Heisenberg uncertainty
relation applies?
Well, one is we have
to be really careful.
It predicts the outcome
of a single measurement
on a single quantum system.
Let me write that down.
Or if the Heisenberg
uncertainty relation
sets a limit, how well we
prepare a quantum system.
It's about a single
quantum system,
and then we perform
a single measurement.
So in a sense, if
we would say all
you have is a single photon,
which is a very special quantum
system.
You have a single
photon and you measure
the frequency of the
photon only once.
Then your will find the limit,
which is the Heisenberg limit.
You cannot, with a single
measurement on a single photon,
determine the accuracy of the
frequency better than this.
And of course, you can
get higher accuracy
by doing repeated measurements
or by using many photons.
We talk about it more in 8.422,
but I just want to remind you,
if you have n
uncorrelated photons.
In other words, we
perform n measurements
on n different objects, then
the signal to noise ratio
is-- just by Poisson
distribution, square root n.
And therefore, the
resolution for the frequency
of the photons is better than
the Heisenberg or the Fourier
limit by 1 over
the square root n.
Some of you-- and actually,
in Professor Vuletic's group,
there is research on it that
if you have correlated-- well,
in his case, correlated atoms.
But if you had
correlated photons,
then you can even do better.
You can reach what is sometimes
called the Heisenberg limit
where you are better
than the limitation
given by Fourier's theorem or
by the Heisenberg uncertainty
relation by a factor of 1/n.
OK.
So as far as the question 2
where the quantum harmonic
oscillator is
concerned, we would
say the answer is
yes, if you have
is single photon at
frequency omega 0,
which interacts with the
quantum harmonic oscillator
at frequency omega 0.
However, the answer
would, even in that case,
be no if you have
harmonic oscillator levels
and you take a photon and
by a nonlinear process
excite the n-th level.
So you have a single photon now.
You can resolve the energy
delta E of this level.
A single photon,
a single quantum
object, you can
define the energy--
that's Heisenberg's
uncertainty relation.
The energy is determined
to that precision.
But your frequency omega
of the optical pulse
is n times omega 0
using nonlinear process.
And then you can determine
the frequency of the harmonic
oscillator, even
for a single quantum
system and a single
photon with a precision
which is 1/n times better.
So you have to be
also careful, but I
don't want to beat
it to death now,
to distinguish between the
accuracy at which Heisenberg's
uncertainty relation
maybe limits
the measurement of
an energy level.
And how this is related
to the frequency
of the harmonic oscillator.
And by going sort of
immediately to the n-th level,
you can, of course, measure
the distance between two levels
more accurately because you
have increased your [INAUDIBLE].
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I just
got a little confused
about when yes means one
thing and no means one thing.
So you're saying that you can
beat the uncertainty relation
in questions 1, 2, and 3
if you can put it in a way
where you get good
signal to noise?
PROFESSOR: OK, I gave you--
sorry for being complicated,
but the physics is complicated.
I try to give it to you
in different layers.
I first looked at
the classical limit,
which is pretty clear-cut.
Then, I used a laser.
The laser has a
classical limit where
the answer is the same as
in the classical limit.
But then we can talk
also in the laser
in the limit of single photons.
And then I said, OK, the
single photon interacting
with a single
quantum system, this
is really when it is quantum.
And if you have a two-level
system and you [INAUDIBLE]
it with a single
photon, then you
can make a measurement which
is limited by this inequality.
But then I said
there is a caveat.
And this is if you bring
in a nonlinear process.
So if your bring in a nonlinear
process, we can go up n steps.
We can drive-- we can,
by some nonlinearity,
drive the harmonic oscillator
from the ground state
to the n state.
Then, everything we have
said about a single photon
and the measurement of
the resonance and such
applies to this photon.
But the energy level of
the harmonic oscillator
has now been measured with
n times higher precision
because we can divide by n.
So the answer is yes, yes, then
quantum mechanics we cannot
make it more accurate
unless we pull some tricks.
And nonlinear physics
would be a trick.
So in general, the
situation where you really
limit it by this inequality
where your precision is limited
would really only apply to a
single photon, a single quantum
physics, and linear physics.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Maybe just the phrasing.
AUDIENCE: What does delta
t mean for a single photon
measurement?
PROFESSOR: Delta t
could be the time
you allow yourself to
make the measurement.
You have a
measurement apparatus.
You switch it on,
you switch it off.
Eventually, you want to
get out of grad school.
I mean, you don't want to take
an infinite amount of time
for the measurements.
There's always a
window, delta t,
and there's a fundamental limit.
The duration of the measurement
limits the precision
of the measurement.
OK.
The next thing I want to
discuss is the analogy, but also
the differences between
a harmonic oscillator
and a two-level system.
So what is a two-level system?
Well, it's a system
with two levels.
What is a harmonic oscillator?
Well, it's a system which
has an infinite number
of equidistant levels.
I will tell you tell you
later in this course when
we talk about the AC
and DC stark effect,
you talk about the
polarizability and light
scattering that you can regard
the atom or the electron
in the atom as a
harmonic oscillator.
An atom scatters light
exactly in the same way
as the charge which is connected
to some support structure
with a spring.
How an oscillating charge
would scatter light?
Well, you know of course, the
atom is a two-level system.
And the sort of model I make
for the electron as a harmonic
oscillator at a single
resonance frequency, which
is 100% exact in the limit
of [? low ?] laser power.
Well, this realize is
a harmonic oscillator.
So therefore, what I'm
telling you by this example,
that there are situations
where a two-level system
and a harmonic
oscillator are the same.
Or, create the same
[? observance, ?]
create the same physics.
Do you have any idea when the
two systems may look the same
or when the two systems
react exactly in the same way
to, for instance,
external radiation?
AUDIENCE: At very
low temperatures?
PROFESSOR: At very
low temperature?
Well--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well, we assume these
are atoms and we always
start in the common state.
So let's assume we
have 0 temperature.
We have an atom.
And maybe what I'm asking is,
if I excite the atom and I said,
there may be a situation where
the atom is a two-level system
but it reacts like a
harmonic oscillator,
when does it break down?
AUDIENCE: When the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
When we go beyond
the perturbative
limit when we use a
strong excitation.
So in other words-- and I
like to give you the answer
before I give you the full
explanation, which now comes.
If you start out in
the ground state,
you can see at 0 temperature, we
have mainly all the population
there.
If you start now
driving the system,
we put-- and I will say a
little bit more about it.
A little bit into
the excited state.
But it is the nature of a
harmonic oscillator when
you put something
into the excited state
that immediately a little bit
goes into the second excited
state.
And this is, of course,
something which you can only do
in a harmonic oscillator but
you cannot do in a level system.
So to the extent that
we have weak excitation
and we can neglect the
excitation in higher levels.
To that extent, a two-level
system and harmonic oscillator
are identical.
Actually, what I'm
saying appears trivial,
but I really want you
to think about it.
It's actually a very
profound statement.
When can you describe a
quantum-mechanical system
as a harmonic oscillator?
For weak excitation
when all what matters
is that you have put a
small fraction of the system
into the first excited state.
And you immediately realize that
the feature which distinguishes
a two-level system from
a harmonic oscillator
is the phenomenon of,
let's say, saturation.
You cannot go higher.
If you do not saturate
a two-level system,
it behaves like a
harmonic oscillator.
And therefore, it behaves
completely classical.
OK, let's work that
out a little bit.
I'll give you some examples.
So the phenomenon of a two-level
system is it has saturation.
The maximum energy you
can put in is one quantum.
Whereas, a harmonic oscillator
can never be saturated.
Just think of the harmonic
oscillator potential parabola.
You can drive the system
as high as you want.
So you can go in this
classical language
to arbitrarily large amplitudes.
So what I just mentioned
where the equivalence holds--
I always want you to
have an example in mind--
is the Lorentz model for an
atom where you describe the atom
as an electron connected
with a spring to the nucleus.
And as we will see
in a few weeks,
this model gives the
identical answer,
identical to the
quantum-mechanical treatment
for probabilities like
the polarizability
and the index of refraction
for gas of atoms or molecules.
So if you have a
two-level system,
we can often think we have
an s, ground state, and then
p, excited state.
And if you do a
weak excitation, we
have sort of a wave
function, which is all,
lets say, positive
one side-- one sign.
And then we [INAUDIBLE]
a p orbital,
which has a note which
is positive and negative.
And now we have the
positive-negative
and the positive and the--
there is the resonance
frequency between the two.
And that together results
in an oscillating dipole.
So the simple model
of superimposing
an s state and a p state
at a certain frequency
gives us an oscillating
dipole, which
is the realization of
a harmonic oscillator.
But the harmonic
oscillator, it oscillates.
And this is, of course,
valid for sufficiently small
excitation.
So the question we
have already addressed
in the discussion,
what is small?
So "small" means population
of higher-excited states
is negligible.
So in other words, as long as
the excitation of the first
excited state is small, then
we can neglect the excitation
in the second excited state,
which is even smaller.
So let me kind of bring
out the difference
between a two-level system
and a harmonic oscillator
a little bit more by discussing
the situational of cavity QED.
Let's assume we want 100%
population in the first excited
state.
If you have a
harmonic oscillator
and the system is prepared
in the first excited state,
this is also called Fock state
with one quantum of excitation.
And it's a rather special state
where people have worked hard
to generate it because you
cannot realize it in a harmonic
oscillator.
And let me sort of explain
that in the following way.
If you have a
harmonic oscillator,
you start and you
would drive it.
And you try to put 100%
in the n equals 1 state.
Before you have accumulated
100% in the n equals 1 state,
you drive it already
to higher states.
And of course, you
know when you start
driving a harmonic
oscillator, classical
or quantum-mechanically, you
create a coherent state, which
is a superposition
of excited states.
So we would say an n equals
1 state cannot be excited.
We usually get a
coherent state, which
is a superposition of many,
or at least several, states.
Whereas in a
two-level system, we
can just do a [INAUDIBLE] pulse.
And to put all the atoms
in the excited state
is nothing special.
Whereas, to have a cavity
filled with photons
and selectively excite
the n equals 1 state,
this is special
because it's not easy.
It's not straightforward.
So in cavity QED,
you can do it if you
have anharmonicities
or nonlinearities.
So let me explain that.
Well, it's an anharmonicity
or some form of-- so
if you have a
situation where you
have your harmonic oscillator,
but the energy levels
are not equidistance.
So the difference between this
first and second excited state
are not the same, then
you can drive the system.
You can prepare Fock
state in n equals
1 like in a two-level system.
And you're out of resonance
to drive it to higher states.
So here, what you utilize is
a sort of two-level system.
And that allows you to create
those special state which
are regarded as
non-classical, very
special states of the
harmonic oscillator.
And one way how you
can create it-- well,
if you have an empty
cavity, each photon
has the same energy.
Then you have an equidistant
harmonic oscillator.
But if you put, for instance--
you add an atom to the cavity,
and the radiation is
interacting with the atom,
then you'll get-- we'll
talk about it later.
The atom and the photons
interact with the Rabi
frequency, and then
you get a splitting,
called the normal
mode splitting.
And this level splitting
is proportional to the Rabi
frequency.
And we'll discuss it
later, but many of you
know that the Rabi
frequency scales
with the square root
of the photon number.
So therefore, you
have a splitting
which is proportional to
square root 1, square root
2, square root 3.
And you have a spectrum
which is no longer
an equidistant system.
And then you can create
non-classical states
of the photon field,
of a harmonic oscillator.
So anyway, I thought I
wanted to bring it up
at the beginning of the
class, because a lot what
we are discussing
in this class is
we'll rediscover in
many situations--
in atoms, in the
light, in the way how
light and atoms interact,
harmonic oscillators
and two-level systems.
Often, I say they are the same.
They behave in the same way.
But I hope this introductory
[? mark ?] tells you, when can
you think in one
limit and when do you
have to apply the other limit?
Any questions about that?
Yes, Nancy.
AUDIENCE: So are we saying
here that without changing
the [INAUDIBLE] of the
harmonic oscillator,
we cannot use it as a
harmonic oscillator?
Like [INAUDIBLE]?
Because when you put an atom
in that [INAUDIBLE] changed,
it was no more a
harmonic oscillator.
The levels changed.
PROFESSOR: Maybe
all I'm saying is
this is a pure
harmonic oscillator.
And in a pure
harmonic oscillator,
I think it's-- I don't
know a proof of it,
but it seems impossible to
prepare a system in the first
excited state because every
attempt to put an excitation
into the system would
carry it higher up.
You would create a wave packet.
You would create
a superposition.
So you have to do some thing.
You have to break the
degeneracy of the spectrum
of the harmonic oscillator.
Of course, what you can do
is you can put in an atom.
You can use the atom as an
aid to just put in exactly one
photon into your cavity, and
then you can remove the atom.
Then you are back to an
ideal harmonic oscillator,
but you have overcome
the limitation
of the harmonic oscillator
in preparing certain states.
Another take-home message you
may take from this discussion
is harmonic
oscillators-- yes, we
have quantum
harmonic oscillators.
But even the quantum
harmonic oscillator
follows a classical description.
So the real quantumness-- what
makes quantum optics quantum
optics and cavity QED a
wonderful example of quantum
physics is the physics
embedded in a two-level system.
That we can put one quantum
excitation into something,
exactly one is as much
quantum as you can get.
This is realized in
a two-level system
and this is related to the
phenomenon of saturation.
You can saturate a
two-level system,
but you cannot saturate
a harmonic oscillator.
So with that, let me
make the transition
to another simple system.
And we want to spend
some time on it.
And these are rotating systems.
So a system which rotates.
Well, what do you think?
Will it behave, using
the discussion we just
had, more like a
classical system
or more like a
quantum-mechanical system?
Of course, I gave you a
very special definition.
What brings out quantum
mechanics in a system?
The harmonic oscillator
is always linear.
You can drive it as
hard as you want.
You drive it hundred
times stronger
and the reaction is
hundred times more.
Everything is linear.
The quantumness of a two-level
system comes from saturation.
What about a rotating system?
Something which
can go in a circle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So you're not going to have
this degeneracy [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, very good.
You're immediately applying
what is the spectrum.
The spectrum is not
equidistant, so it
should bring in a difference.
It's sometimes hard to
ask a simple question
without giving the answer away.
But what I had in
mind was a gyroscope,
a gyroscope which is precessing.
And what I wanted
to sort of lead you
with the question is, if you
have something which rotates,
the amplitude is limited.
A rotating object, let's assume
a magnetic, classical magnetic
moment.
It can have a precession
angle which is 180 degrees,
but that's a maximum.
In other words, the rotating
system when you excite it
has a maximum amplitude,
exactly as a two-level system.
So that's what a rotating
system and a two-level system--
actually then, I'm
now specializing
on more rotating gyroscope.
If you have a free
rotator, this, of course,
can rotate with [INAUDIBLE]
angular momentum
and the excitation spectrum
would not be bound.
So I think I have to rephrase
the question the next time
I teach the class.
I wanted to ask you here about
a special rotating system, which
is a precessing gyroscope.
So rotating system.
If you think about
precessing gyroscope,
it has a bound on the
amplitude it can be excited.
So what I want to show you,
today and in the next lecture,
is the motion of classical
magnetic moments.
When you think about the motion
of classical magnetic moments,
think about a compass
needle, a magnetized needle
which has angular momentum.
And then, the system is acted
upon with a magnetic field.
So this is our system.
And if angular momentum,
magnetic moments, and torque
come into play, we have the
physics of classical rotation.
But the excitation
spectrum here is limited
because you can flip
a compass needle
and this is a
maximum excitation.
When the North Pole points in
the opposite direction, that's
the maximum excitation
you can give it.
So therefore, it has a limited
amplitude of its excitation,
unlike a harmonic oscillator.
And at this point you may
say, but maybe somewhat
similar or analogous
to a two-level system.
But the surprising
result is-- at least
it was surprising when I
first learned about it.
That it's not just
somewhat analogous
to a two-level
system, it actually
captures exactly a
lot of the properties
of the dynamics of
a two-level system.
So let me write that down.
The motion of classical magnetic
moments provides a model.
It's actually an
exact model which
captures essentially
all features
of the quantum mechanical
two-level system.
I want to show you today and
the next lecture the concepts
or Rabi frequency, of
generalized of resonant Rabi
frequency, all of that you
find in the classical motion
of a magnetic moment.
Or, for instance, the
physics of rapid [INAUDIBLE]
following, [INAUDIBLE].
A lot of physics
we would usually
associate with the
quantum system,
we find it here in a
purely classical system.
What aspects of the two-level
system will we not find?
Any ideas?
Will?
AUDIENCE: Spontaneous emission?
PROFESSOR: Spontaneous
emission, definitely.
Yes.
But actually, in a
two-level system,
in a quantum-mechanical
two-level system, which
we drive with a
single frequency,
spontaneous emission
is also missing.
Spontaneous emission, as
we will discuss later,
only comes into play when we say
the excited state of the system
interacts with many,
many modes and not just
the one mode we apply.
And typically, if you
go to high frequency,
we have an optical oscillator,
we cannot avoid spontaneous
emission.
Whereas, for a
quantum-mechanical spin 1/2
interacting with microwaves,
we can completely
eliminate spontaneous emission.
So spontaneous
emission, I would say,
comes into play
at high frequency.
So that's correct.
But there is one aspect
even at low frequency,
one aspect of quantum mechanics
which we cannot capture.
AUDIENCE: Having different
G in a magnetic field?
PROFESSOR: Different
G factors, yes.
That's, as we see, a
more quantitative aspect.
But there is one very important
feature about quantum mechanics
you will never get in
a classical system.
AUDIENCE: Spin?
PROFESSOR: Spin.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
I think you're skirting around.
It's a quantum measurement
process and projection.
If you perform a measurement
on a compass needle,
it can be at any angle.
But if you do a measurement
on a quantum system,
you do a projection.
After the measurement
projects a system
in either spin up or spin down.
So the probabilistic
nature, the projection
occurring in a
quantum measurement
is, of course, absent
in a classical system.
But when you say spin
1/2 and quantum levels,
this is sort of implied in it.
If there are only two levels,
there's only up and down
and not an infinite
number of angles.
So what we will actually see is
that we find an exact analogy
between the classic system and
the quantum mechanical system
when we compare
expectation values.
But the individual measurement,
the individual quantum
measurement because it is
projective is different.
OK, with that
motivation, we are now
talking about
magnetic resonance.
And we will later do a fully
quantum mechanical description,
but to get the concepts and
also understand the analogies
to a classical system,
we want to understand
what happens when we have
a classic magnetic moment
in magnetic fields.
And that includes static
fields, but then we
want to excite the system.
We want to drive the system,
and this is time-varying fields.
And we will assume that the
fields are spatially uniform.
So let me just remind you of
the obvious equations of motion
that also allows me to
introduce the nomenclature.
The interaction energy between
a classical magnetic moment
mu and the magnetic
field is mu dot B.
The force is the gradient
of the interaction energy,
but it is 0 for uniform fields.
So therefore, we don't
need to look at the force.
But the next thing which we then
have to consider is the torque.
And when we think about the
classical magnetic moment,
you can think about
a compass needle.
But magnetic materials
are complicated.
If I think about the
simplest magnetic moment,
I think about a loop of
current I and area A.
And that's sort of the classical
model for magnetic moment.
So we have a magnetic moment mu.
And if we now add a magnetic
field, which is at an angle,
we have a torque.
But just to make
sure the torque is
something which is nothing
else than the Lewin's
force on the electrons.
But since electron is
forced to go in a circle,
we don't have to look at the
Lewin's force microscopically.
We just immediately
jump to the torque.
And the torque is what describes
the dynamics of the system.
So we have torque.
When we have torque, we want
to formulate the problem
in terms of angular momentum.
And our equation of motion
is the classical equation
of motion that the derivative
of angular momentum
is given by that.
Now, what makes those equations
immediately solvable--
and to find the
very easy limit is
that the magnetic moment
of the system we assume
is proportional to
its angular momentum.
Well, if you have a
mechanical object which
goes in a-- if you have a
charged object which circles
around a central potential,
then you, of course,
find immediately that
if it moves faster,
it has more angular momentum.
It has a larger magnetic moment.
So we use that as the
defining equation for what
is called the
gyromagnetic ratio.
Which, of course, is
very closely related
to G factors, which we
define later on for atoms.
The gyromagnetic ratio is the
ratio between magnetic moment
and angular momentum.
And then, we find that the
derivative of angular momentum
is given by this equation.
And this is now
an equation which
you have seen in
classical mechanics
and in many situations.
The solution of that
is a pure precession.
The motion is pure precession
of the angular momentum
around the axis of
the magnetic field.
So in other words, we have the
axis of the magnetic field.
We have the angular momentum.
And at a constant
tipping angle, we
have the tip of the
angular momentum
precesses around
the magnetic field.
And the precession happens
with an angular frequency
which is called the
Larmor frequency.
The Larmor frequency, the
frequency of precession,
is proportional to
the magnetic field
and the gyromagnetic ratio.
So let me give you an
example for an electron.
The gyromagnetic ratio is 2 pi
times 2.8 megahertz per Gauss.
And we've discussed
last class what
it means when I take out 2 pi.
Because the Larmor frequency
is an angular frequency.
And angular frequency
is not measured in Hertz
because there is a 2 pi factor.
And I just make it obvious
where the 2 pi factor is hidden.
Now, this is for the electron.
But if you have an ensemble
of classical charges,
an [INAUDIBLE] distribution
of classical charges--
well, with the same
charge to mass ratio,
you find that the gyromagnetic
ratio is 1/2 of that.
And this here is
the Bohr magneton,
which we will use quite
often in this course.
The third example is the proton.
The proton is heavier,
has a heavier mass.
About 1,000 times heavier
than the electron.
And therefore, the
Larmor frequency is not
megahertz per Gauss, it
is kilohertz per Gauss.
Any questions?
These are more definitions
and setting the stage.
Let me make a note.
It's one of the
many notes I will
make in this course
about factors of 2.
There are factors of 2.
If you miss it, you
qualitatively miss the physics.
And let me in that
context by talking
about precession frequencies
and magnetic moment,
explain a factor of
2 which is related
to the G factor of the electron.
So if you have the electron
which has spin of 1/2,
in units of the
Bohr magneton, what
is the magnetic moment
of the electron?
1/2, 1, or 2?
What is the magnetic
moment of the electron?
1/2, 1, or 2?
AUDIENCE: 2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I should have a
clicker question on there.
No.
It's 1.
1 Bohr magneton.
And let me sort of show
the level structure of it.
This is [INAUDIBLE] energy.
You have spin up and
you have spin down.
The difference is 2.8
megahertz per Gauss.
And if you ask, what is
the precession frequency
of an electron in
a magnetic field?
It's 2.8 megahertz if
the field is 1 Gauss.
And if you want to
drive the rotation,
if you want to change the
precession angle-- we'll
talk about that
in great detail--
you better drive the
system at 2.8 megahertz.
But 2.8 megahertz is the
difference of plus 1.4
and minus 1.4.
And therefore, the energy of
the electron in a magnetic field
is either plus or minus
1.4 megahertz per Gauss,
and 1.4 is 1 Bohr magneton.
The magnetic moment of the
electron is 1 Bohr magneton.
So precesses at 2.8.
OK, but let us contrast this
with a classical current
distribution, which has
1 unit of h bar, which
means the magnetic moment
is 1 Bohr magneton exactly
as the electron has.
Well, quantum
mechanically means it
has three different
level-- minus 1,
[INAUDIBLE] 0, and 1 because it
has 1 unit of angular momentum.
Since the system has
1 Bohr magneton, when
the system stands
up or stands down,
the difference between
spin up and spin down
is 2.8 megahertz per Gauss.
OK, my question now is, what
is the precession frequency
of this classical charge
distribution which
has 1 unit h bar of
angular momentum?
And I've just shown you
the level structure.
If you will now create a
wave packet of those three
levels, which means-- a wave
packet of the three levels
means you have a spin which
points in one direction.
What is the precession
frequency of that system?
Let's have a clicker question.
So what is the
precession frequency?
Oops, what happened?
So let me give
you three choices.
2.4, 1.4, or 0.0
megahertz per Gauss.
So please vote for A, B, or C.
Yes, it's 1.4.
So they have the
same magnetic moment.
Quantum mechanically, you would
see here is a G factor of 2.
Here's a G factor of 1.
But the easiest explanation
is it precesses.
The precession is a beat note
between two energy levels.
Here, you have the beat note
between those two energy
levels happens at 1.4 megahertz.
Therefore, when you
want to drive it
with an external
radiation, you have
to drive it at 1.4 megahertz.
You want to drive
it level by level.
Whereas, this system has a
beat note between two levels,
and the difference
is 2.8 megahertz.
Anyway, whenever you get
confused about factors of 2
with magnetic moment
and precessing system,
just think about those
two simple examples.
They have all the factors of 2
hidden in the simplest example
possible.
All right.
We have a rotating system.
have a system which precesses.
So we want to learn about
rotations in general.
And what I want to
show you is that
under very general
circumstances,
we can solve the equation,
the dynamics of the system,
by going into rotating frame.
You all know about
rotating wave [INAUDIBLE]
rotating wave approximations
that's in quantum physics.
I'm simply talking
about a classical system
and I want to
solve the equations
for the classical system
by going to rotating frame.
And I want to show you where
this is exact and where not.
OK, so this is
actually something
which we do in undergraduate,
in 8.01-- definitely, in 8.012.
But let me remind you when we
have a rotating vector which
rotates with a constant
angular frequency,
then the time derivative of the
vector is the cross product.
But now we want
to allow-- so this
is when the vector is
constant and it just rotates.
But now, we want to assume
that there is something else.
There is an arbitrary
time dependence
of the vector in
the rotating frame.
So we have a vector
which changes
according to A dot [INAUDIBLE].
But it also rotates.
And that means--
and this is exactly
shown in classical mechanics
that in the inertia frame,
the time derivative
is the sum of the two.
It is the change of the
vector in the rotating
frame plus omega cross A.
So it has this equation.
Has the simple
two limiting cases
that if there is no change
in the rotating frame,
then we retrieve the
kinematics of pure rotation.
When our rotating
frame is not rotating
or it rotates at 0 angular
frequency, then of course
the two time derivatives
are the same.
But anyway, what I derived for
you is an operator equation
that the time derivative
in the rotating frame
is related to the time
derivative in the inertia
frame in this way.
And now we want to apply it
to our angular momentum L dot.
So this is just applying
the operator equation
to our angular
momentum L. And now
we want to specialize
that-- we just
discussed that the
time [INAUDIBLE].
I'm just looking
for a sign problem,
but it's sometimes hard to fix
sign problems at the board.
The creation of motion
for the angular momentum
was that it's L cross gamma B.
Oh, I changed the order.
There is no sign problem.
And then, I add this.
So if we now describe
our precessing,
classical magnetic moment,
which has the equation of motion
that L dot is L cross
gamma B, if you describe it
in a rotating frame, then
the equation of motion
gets modified as follows.
Now, what happens is we--
let me factor out the gamma.
Gamma L cross B
is the real field.
So what we observe
is that when we
go into a rotating
frame-- and this
is exact-- that the real
magnetic field gets replaced
by an effective magnetic field.
Because there is an
extra term added to it,
which we can call a
fictitious magnetic field.
So this is just an
exact transformation
of our equation of
motion for a precessing
system into the rotating frame.
And now, of course, we
haven't made any assumptions
what the rotating frequency is.
But if you would choose
the rotating frequency
to be the Larmor frequency
minus gamma times B,
then our effective
magnetic field vanishes.
And then we know, because
there is no magnetic field,
that the angular momentum is
constant in the rotating frame.
In other words, the
dynamics of the system
means that L is constant
in a rotating frame.
And if you want to know what
happens in the original,
in the [? lab ?] frame,
in the inertial frame,
we just have to rotate back.
OK, that's something we
want to take advantage of.
But we fully apply
it in the next class.
I have only a few
minutes left today,
and I want to spend
those few minutes to talk
about another factor of 2.
Now, let me ask
you the following.
If you have an electron
in a magnetic field, well,
you know that the
electron goes in circles.
It's the cyclotron
motion of the electron.
Now, just give me one second.
I forgot to mention something
for the classical system.
For a classical
charge distribution,
the Larmor frequency is
the charge of the particle.
In case of the electron, it's e.
Divided by 2m times B.
So the Larmor frequency
is e over 2m times B.
So therefore, we
know that when we
have an [INAUDIBLE] of
positive and negative charges,
and there is an effective
magnetic moment,
that this magnetic moment
would precess at the Larmor
frequency which is given
by this expression.
So who knows what the frequency
of the cyclotron motion is?
So when we have a
free electron, what
is the frequency at
which it revolves?
At which it goes in circles?
AUDIENCE: 2 times
the Larmor frequency.
PROFESSOR: It's two times
OK, I just wanted to mention it.
There's an important factor of
2 which you should know about.
In previous classes, I
spent 10 or 20 minutes
to teach you about
a few of them which
is called Larmor's theorem.
But I summarized the argument
on the atomic physics wiki
and I can't say
more here in class
than I've written on the wiki.
So please read on our
atomic physics wiki
about Larmor's theorem.
Larmor's theorem shows you
that under certain assumptions,
you can transform away the
effect of a magnetic field
by going to the
Larmor frequency.
That looks exactly like
what we have discussed here.
But what we discussed
here was exact.
There was no approximation.
Whereas, the derivation
of Larmor's theorem,
which talks about
charge distributions--
not about magnetic moments,
about charge distributions--
has to make certain
approximations.
So just want to
point your attention
to that there are two
derivations about Larmor
frequency.
One is exact, which
I gave to you.
There is another one which
is Larmor's theorem, which
applies to isolated
charges which is not exact.
But they both conclude
that you can transform away
the effect of a
magnetic field by going
to rotating frame at
the Larmor frequency.
And the fact that Larmor's
theorem is not exact
is actually illustrated by
this example of a free electron
where you have a factor of 2.
And this comes
because the term which
you neglect when you
derive Larmor's theorem
is negligible if
the situation is
that you have electrons
and charges forming
magnetic moments.
But if you have a free
electron, the neglected term
is exactly 1/2 of
the dominant term.
And that is why the
cyclotron frequency is twice
about Larmor frequency.
So never confuse the cyclotron
and the Larmor frequency.
And the factor of
2 is not related
to a G factor of the
electron or such.
It's really the difference
between the physics
of a free charge and the
physics of a magnetic moment.
Any questions?
OK, well, then we are
finished for today.
A reminder, no class
on Wednesday, but we
have class on Friday in
the different classroom.